foreign
colorful groups
often seen dancing and chatting in the
streets
what most Americans think when they hear
Hare Krishna is
peaceful people
[Music]
nothing about making someone disappear
this is the case that's probably going
to be with me for the rest of my life
there are two worlds the material was
and the spiritual world
is young immature people suddenly
acquiring this absolute power over other
human beings
Keith Hamm wanted to take over the
movement
manipulative power hungry he was the
devil incarnate
my father said he's not a real Guru and
my family was destroyed
it's a whoduna why did this guy get shot
and he's connected to the Christmas in
West Virginia
I promised that I would stay for six
months and didn't get out for 11 years
just like the Bob
you can't have a snitch
you didn't go against Keith Hamm
did
we didn't hear from you again
[Music]